sometimes our fearless orange leader
says things very serious and scary
things that are just a little bit
off-balance sometimes though Donald
Trump says things that are so outrageous
so bizarre and out there that I start to
question whether I'm living in some kind
of satirical simulation of the universe
that I've somehow crossed over into some
bizarre metaphysical transition the
likes of which I don't even believe and
is usually reserved for daytime
television psychics and con men and the
latest is that Donald Trump has made a
number of delusional and downright
fantasy world statements in the first
days of his Asia trip earlier in the
program we talked about some of the
things he said in Japan we we are going
to get to what he's been doing in South
Korea but at the top of this list of
bizarre Trump statements from this trip
his Trump's assertion that gun control
in Texas would have left hundreds more
dead in the recent tragic shooting that
took place and did kill 26 people and
injured 20 what exactly did Trump say
check this out this is Donald Trump's
answer right after being asked about hey
you support extreme vetting for
immigration what about extreme vetting
for buying guns and here's what Donny
boy had to say if you did what you're
suggesting there would have been no
difference three days ago and you might
not have had that very brave person who
happened to have a gun or a rifle in his
truck go out and shoot him and hit him
and neutralize him and I can only say
this if he didn't have a gun instead of
having 26 dead he would have had
hundreds more dead so that's the way I
feel about it and you're not gonna help
hundreds more dead now on its face what
Trump is saying is is not true right the
shooter in Texas ultimately shot himself
after shooting people outside the church
inside the church fleeing crashing his
car into a ditch and ultimately took his
own life right that's number one
secondly the police in Vegas had
a month ago armed police are everywhere
in Las Vegas it still was of no help
until they actually went up dozens of
stores into a hotel 400 yards away and
went into the guys hotel room but the
truly weird thing that Trump said and
Trump is hear it and they accepted hook
line and sinker is that hundreds more
would have died it's just not true right
this hero neighbor engaged the shooter
after he had already shot up the outside
and inside of the church and was leaving
and of course killing 26 people is
tragic every one of those deaths and the
20 injuries are tragic but under what
circumstances would the shooter have
killed hundreds were it not for this
neighbor with a gun the church is tiny
the entire town of Sutherland Springs
Texas has a population that barely
reaches 500 people total so what
scenario would have led to this gunman
killing hundreds had there been gun
safety laws if there were gun safety
laws more than half of the entire town
would have been killed is that what
Donald Trump is saying and you really
need to think kind of hard here right
because Trump is relying on generalities
if it was tougher for a good guy the
neighbor to get a gun the bad guy would
have been able to kill hundreds of
people in this particular incident
explain to me specifically how 100%
background checks would have changed
this incident for the worst are you
saying that there's something in the
neighbors past that would have blocked
him from getting a gun if there were
100% background checks that would be
weird I don't think that that's what
you're arguing are you saying I don't
know that limits on automatic weapons
would have changed this and allowed the
gunman to kill more people how exactly
think critically and analyze every
aspect of the claim and you will very
quickly see that it completely falls
apart and then when you really think
about it the the truly sick irony of
this is that if the Air Force hadn't
messed up right if the air force system
worked well if a clerk in the Air Force
had done their job and reported the
gunman's issues the conviction in the
military the gunman would not have been
able to legally buy guns in the first
place and those 26 people might be alive
today the right likes this simplistic
thinking Trump
feeds it gun control would have led to
hundreds more dead but the truth is that
if we were actually using or enforcing
the gun safety and reporting
requirements that are already on the
books not new ones the ones that are
already on the books we might not have
been relying on some clerk in the Air
Force to do their job correctly if we
could restructure that reporting system
to be more foolproof and the gunman
might not have had these guns in the
first place so this is dangerous and
it's immoral and it's appealing to the
oh the most simplistic lowest common
denominator that we have here and we all
need to really critically analyze every
single one of these claims what what is
implied by Donald Trump saying thank
goodness we didn't have more gun safety
laws because if we did the shooter might
have killed hundreds more delusional
claim impossible to back up empirically
think about it do not be bamboozled by
the bamboozler and chief donald trump
let's take a break we'll be back after
this I want to talk about the latest
with the Puerto Rico Power contract that
was cancelled and also some very bizarre
voicemails on today's program the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad